welcome to this video
yeah it's a war zone tournament coming
up here I just decided I want to play
one today and when I was looking and
this is coming up in a couple of seconds
it's a three minutes tournament so not
as quick and action-packed maybe as
usual but I still think it might be
interesting to wash it down it's three
minutes and it's it's running for 45
minutes total so it's a bit of a longer
tournament let's see what happens
so probably should place to sharp stuff
so I will play a bit a bit more dicey
and than usual probably like this
f5 probably not the best opening ever
but very well suited to irritate the
opponent
yeah not sure what's best here actually
maybe um maybe taking it now maybe okay
I'll just try to get an e-form
yeah I'll get the pawn back simply it
would also be quite nice yeah let's just
get the pawn back if he takes f6 I need
to take with the pawn queen of 695
always trying to try to to win something
in the center directly interesting hmm I
wonder if I should try you for him and
it's probably not good no but maybe I
can I can just make a sacrifice out of
this 9595 there's actually also 94 95 95
94 could be nice if I can take the Queen
then yeah I think I can do that here
it's quite funny probably has to go back
now and then I'm the one with Queenie
seven coming and then I have at least
have a very nice development maybe there
is some drawback but I don't see it at
the moment on any check I just take the
Queen 96 check 92 98 93 should be very
good for me to put it mildly Mia he's
not moving I think he needs to okay yeah
this is also probably interesting if I
take here and then now g4 I guess yeah
but then even Queenie 7 is a good move
94-92 Knight f6 check gf
Bishop e2 d4 actually my is a 3 but are
not g4 I can also just just move the
Queen I can just move the Queen and
let's say here and it should be a double
attack if it plays Queen e6 Bishop e6 I
have a I can play 93 I overlook that hmm
that was somewhat stupid okay I'll get
the pawn back but it wasn't it wasn't
like I had planned things the Pena will
get them get the pawn back I'm also
threatening deform maybe he must play a3
him oh he's just just just overstepping
the time I guess without ever getting
any quicker in his play totally relaxed
about the time lost
okay yeah some guys have three games
played it I was I was decently quick but
he took all this time okay let's see you
try - okay need to try try to win
quickly okay I'll take that
yeah just retreating from from h6 on h6
it's always somewhat exposed I mean if I
can do here and now try to trap the rook
the rook has no squares it's gone I mean
even also King FY okay everyone is got
Queen h3 not sure I want to want to do
that so let's oak let's let's exchange
some more stuff queenie for queenie -
yes that's just a rock let's let's
return a bit of material - to break
through yeah Camryn c2 c1 that make sure
that the rook is not entering
you know he's continuing the spider
chances being very low that there is
something happening okay okay so um I
see what jumped ahead him the guy with
three games now hasn't hasn't wanting
game after that okay resigning quickly
that's nice let's see I wanted to play
you for actually playing a bit sharper
yeah maybe I can play some some sharp
stuff after the four to get to get them
resigning very often yeah I mean it's
nice to get to get those quick resigns
once the new are too and to just score
points but it's not really just content
seeing people declining them the dulling
cube all the time
yeah please leave feedback also if you
want to do what you think about there
was somewhat longer time control games
in war zone format now this game is not
starting hmm strange truly weird they
had those type of problems really even
one or two years ago and have not been
able to solve it obviously
yeah please write to me what you think
about those somewhat longer time control
games in the war zone format should I
play those kind of tournaments more
often three minutes obviously longer
does not really make much sense I don't
think there isn't I think there is a
five-minute format it's there I'm not
sure there are some some tournaments are
there with with the three-minute format
not often I won't play this these
terribly often but once in a while and I
would like to know if this is an
interesting format to you so no I got I
got a different opponent yeah let's just
play play it aggressively an opponent is
going for hippopotamus set up long
castles okay blundering e5 but still
this is some very dangerous choice
okay how can i maybe him Bishop before
coming
yeah didn't really believe in that so
much but yeah you can do it especially
we can play we could be for those kind
of strange numbers that wasn't good
simply bad plane I can still provoked
you for okay come on I need to get rid
of this Bishop this also could have been
answered cheerfully
yeah let's get out of the pins I also
have some ideas here with my to be five
but to get out of the checks can go here
intending rook a seven and three takes
the screen deform you know I can
actually give the checker maybe Queen
here queen F form a cuneiform
well I can play rook t1 now my week back
rank is is a problem the rook t1 hmm
I actually probably have to play rubgy
one maybe I can do that
non-threatening night a six and stuff
you know if he takes this ever I take T
- yeah maybe still rock do you want
but somehow it does not do it
I don't down look do you wonder I think
it's just winning and it hmm okay no
this is hanging really yeah that's not
it's not really working you can flavor
earn carob 96 but this king c6
poor we had game very weird game can
just take the night
I cannot do all this without without a
back rank ya can only hope for for some
some big blunder um
this is sort of one getting back getting
back one can make a piece you can give a
check if it is only one check wow that's
some counter play now but all this is
taking ages 26 rock d6 King see if I if
it's really playable no it isn't i has
yes he's got a queen you and now I have
this one this is made King King c5 I
thought I can take it King b6 Queen to
f8 yeah ok this was very lucky just a
bad game and this is the director
pursue him let's see if I can do some
funny
gambit stuff I know he's doing funny
gambit stuff not really great this kind
of gambit with different F form in blitz
chess can can do many things
yeah essentially a White has sacrificed
a piece he has the worst King position
and the worst development so I'm it's
not really great let's see I take him or
D 394 I have Bishop c5 here I cannot
really this is not really something to
fear but I want to play Bishop c5 anyway
you know like this John White
what does not have any space yeah the
pawns on c4 and d 4 are completely
hindering his flame not going to take
that
okay I wonder no that's okay
94 I can take 93 and when I look in the
corner get rid of the spawn before it
gets really really dangerous
next might be three bishop deform to
come would be nice
okay this he prevented but after age six
where do you go Knight f3 I take f4
before I could have taken anyway I think
look at for Queen g5 but I really don't
see what him what is nothing now yeah I
have 92 also maybe do that and then take
on c4
yeah I'm just winning winning a piece on
c4 and mmm also take with an idea even
where's the Queen going it's a it's
their square I don't see one I think I
have more squares
Queen is trapped it's really funny but
all all pieces together take away all
Queen squares the night's the night on e
2 takes away f4 and g3 this night takes
away bee tuna yeah that's it for the
Queen and again we have 6 maybe it does
not really matter
taking taking the rookie I mean double
attacking you can take d3 though yeah
well just only just take the rook
yeah let's take a bit simple yeah just a
mop-up job not quite sure when continues
yeah it's this is a typical thing in
those those tournaments and small don't
tournaments resigning is actually
helping him as well because he can get a
new game and earn new points um yeah
where's the meat
yes one okay this guy is no point but
1800 rating yeah let's let's maybe can
can play some aggressive stuff here
maybe the Evans gambit a nice opening
which I have some respect of some
respect off not sure if this is the
right right word okay mmm yeah what
normally has some compensation
it's yeah Bishop e2 is also possibly
instead of Bishop d3 but this Bishop d3
is an interesting move
let's see black zone position is
certainly not bad I played this as black
as well but white also has some
compensation it's not like it's totally
easy for black to play um mmm
Knight yeah maybe get the night over to
the Kings side
okay I take one pawn back here maybe
it's I'm not sure but with this typical
trick I wouldn't have one pawn back
I give up the important LightSquared
bishop and this is why I'm not really
sure this was a good idea but the
compensation was slightly was slightly
fishy so I don't mind to to get them get
the pawn back reading this shouldn't be
too bad for white it's nothing special
yeah but certainly a playable line or
play with a paper position let's see hmm
hmm maybe here I don't see five I have a
d5 and control the square and a ticket
for okay it looks like it wouldn't move
it started doing many things at the same
time
yeah before but probably get lost him
some pawn up good trend from being one
point down now being one point up okay I
don't mind therefore this was a plan
anyway
now I can even advance further why not
yeah here Africa for orgies reah
both went with the piece that's maybe
easier okay for maybe maybe g5 but yeah
I can take him take with the Queen but
he has this chick iam
okay keep it keep it simple
who takes rook takes the knight is still
trapped on g5 I can also just retreat
and it has no squares don't want to give
a p5
and and promotes I hope to pause on the
seventh that's normally too much okay
yeah eight out of eight
oh I'm playing again the direct direct
pursue a young place to let's see maybe
maybe here okay yeah I would have played
the trucks long but he didn't didn't
allow that okay well this is interesting
maybe I can no I can get some something
going here with g5 can i play with long
castling
maybe maybe oh that's good news he is
weakening the kingside if sri is really
a bad move
let's see
yeah maybe directly bishop takes on
Knight takes bishop change I guess yeah
yeah but not sure that it's doing so
much many many replies I can also play
complain I'd h5 and I can take e for him
taking e4 is the most straightforward
way
yeah maybe night age 5 I'm not sure not
sure this was hanging because of the be
6x6 thing I mean hanging after D takes
e5 ok star threat no I don't want to
draw really not just no threat really I
can also take him and now maybe you just
get out of this to have Queen h3 or g8
what's the quickest way to play that
maybe this one we are first taking a
truck g8y this must be the quickest
Queen h4 and queen h3 made and queen g2
made I mean all kinds of mates no maybe
he wants to resign and does not find the
button and instead tries to offer a draw
I know I found the button that's good
okay yeah keeping the lead and it's a
pretty substantial one now about 30
points yeah this tournament is by the
way I'm one of those I know it's called
VIP tournament I know it's one of those
or at least I'd say I'm let's I try to
describe it didn't do you need to have
fun experience on level never ladies
code of 150 to participate and I'm 200
something so I'm allowed it basically
means that there are no no new players
allowed to participate
it's basically restricted to to longer
longer term members okay good good dance
control maybe Bishop g2 and try to try
to attack that d5 Knight yeah I tend to
get nervous in the C file maybe yeah
maybe it wasn't really any of any
importance I must I must be very
cautious about 93 here hmm this can
easily lead to trouble try to get the
Queen's off here
Knight takes and this night is free this
is the problem anyway right III know 96
year maybe we can give the check but
it's not really a problem ok so I want a
pond and I have the distemper on the
apron oh this is checkmate okay that
made the technical part or not easier it
was very good for white because I had to
not only the poem but it also I'm a very
good young active position so he was
some certainly am
yeah somewhat passive okay let's see yes
is he was disconnected
okay and should we connect within two
minutes it's this is quite a long time
okay here we go
get a French defense by transposition
this is this blunder we takes this 95
yeah I cannot really believe in this
plate maybe now maybe a five was sauce
was not for great run I wanted to play a
fine actually
oops oops maybe maybe we regroup him
mmm yeah G for him
G for can be M can be really dangerous
G 497 I guess I need to get out of here
as quickly as possible probably here so
that after G 4 I can take with the night
or maybe take first sure take first
pressure on g7 is it's quite substantial
anyway
yeah that is simply not good he has a
very very active in promising position
here I don't have the time to castle
yeah this looks crazy but I don't really
see how to defend g7 certainly white is
much better now boom really thought you
would just take I mean does this one
would have been dangerous yeah I can
easily give up the exchange here don't
mind that really glad that the position
is closed now the exchange does not
matter him with all all lines being
closed now that that's actually quite
nice for me Black has the play now on
the unresponsive
maybe if I cannot take and this is a big
check with the bishop yeah maybe
take take one pawn back
this is a strong light it looks very
dangerous
I drew a true also in the mix I don't
really have a good square
maybe maybe here I can even but I must
play I must play quicker I have seen
that this hanging but I want to take
drugs and play against F form yeah he's
got this check him but only one check to
my can we can enter here with with the
Queen maybe Queen's right I have
enormous compensation him like an item
it's exclusively playing on time but I'm
not so slow buddy okay so it still a
clean score I would I was in big trouble
in this game he also could have instead
of g5 just just taken on a fire first
this would would be a WoW position oh
yeah I can play say we are gambit here
taking would have been better actually
but okay at least it led to a nice
position
it's pushing back and now let's see if
it's very very aggressive position
already here on the on the kingside
maybe just try to get pieces over
threatening me six no but yeah I know I
get night two affair he must do
something like that but I have the night
on f5 yeah that five night is the famous
spar off night as he said with a night
on a fire I'm unstoppable
it's probably right okay maybe I can get
in a quick medium okay
well it looks pretty comfortable six
minutes left in this tournament and now
I finally understand why I'm not gaining
any rating points there is underrated
okay I mean okay the rating points are
totally unimportant I was just wondering
is always exactly this this same figure
all the time should die at least gain
one point point per game or anything no
it's it's underrated okay very weird
opening him it started as a bank oh well
it is technically a Banco but very
strange still no kept maybe I can't I
Queen f6 was my idea
double attacking a1 and the bishop
leading to some funny play now how does
he protect those he doesn't yeah I
really didn't see what he should do here
to get Queen a5 and just an additional
annoyance or this chick yeah what get
let's start start here not before it's
not a check of course okay you cannot
castle maybe I should develop some stuff
just cancelling this should be seven our
best bet I guess off first I could go
here actually yeah let's get rid of the
bishop this should be seven runs into
Queen aged seven medium that's not very
advisable
yeah yeah I don't like it
giving up the bishop here but what can
you do I get a new nice piece on
deformed oh yeah this is nicely covering
this second rank and now I need to get
the Queen near the king and to check on
a line scram mmm we asked the maid maybe
this year
threatening f6 winning the Queen f6
takes Bishop takes once the Queen oh
this is made okay so two minutes 40 left
maybe I can get in a new game 13 games
this is a lucky number on unlucky number
who's hit at this bar off he was always
telling that this is the lucky number
he's the 13 through our champion and so
on
okay it's still warm yeah it's pretty
much pretty much impossible to win
quickly but I try to at least play
currently yeah if I go G for I open up
his Bishop but this means I need to time
it correctly I don't think he wants to
open up him no he wants so this is a
nice position technically with him
having all the the bed bed with the
better corneum and the bed structure
very comfortable position but there's
only one minute 17 left
but I'm better not not that quickly it's
really unfortunate I would have really
liked to play this out just to see if I
can they can win it it's a it's really
not a winning position or anything but
oh it's nicer to play this kind of zero
counter play positions yeah I get a
winning position indeed at the end but
yeah I only have to have seconds left
oh maybe it's not winning
of course it's winning he has the neat
plan so it's just checkmate now in a
couple of minutes but okay I couldn't I
couldn't do it it was just a couple of
seconds at the end this whole position
was it was too close okay I wonder I
wonder whole thing let's look at the
final standing I was so very much ahead
at the end I got in 13 games which is I
think okay and yeah I had some even some
very quick reasoner's right at the start
yeah this is a bit of a different rhythm
with three minutes per game it's uh it's
really not comparable to bullet but what
I did the last two days so I enjoyed
playing those once in a while and at the
moment I really have some time on my
hands I'd like to play them so if you
enjoy it right write me some feedback
what about three minute war zones are
they okay thanks and I'll be back soon
with new videos of that type bye